[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I can't believe we had to resort to
eating Carl we've known him since we
were kids
I I know but
we've we've been stuck in this bomb
shelter since the invasion
I know
I know and you know what the worst part
is
I'm not even full yet
me either
I'm so hungry
let me grab my Patriot Supply
boom
what you've
you had that the entire time
yeah I forgot I bought it like there's
like 10 of them we ate a human being we
did but now we have macaroni and cheese
and oatmeal and uh ooh pancakes
and oh my favorite
pudding
pudding
this changes everything I love pudding
[Music]
hey Carl you want some
I guess not cuttings for a live people
only
I'm out I need yours
oh no I eat you
my Patriot Supply
delicious and a whole lot better than
eating Carl
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
OS
spirits
all right no sip today and the reason is
because it's too hot
you're learning yeah I got close to it
uh we have a lot to get to here today by
the way uh Dave Landau is uh still gone
but uh uh yeah I don't know how but he
had a family member who had some surgery
and just so you know your prayers are
very much appreciated seems things are
going well there's still some
information that remains to be seen Dave
miss you love you and uh we will see him
soon still comment below hit the like
button let them know that uh boy does
that seem exploitative just if you don't
hit the like button you hate David yeah
if you don't hit the like button you
want his family members to die that's
rude of you too so uh but in his place
actually is I don't call him this but
Dave calls him this and now everyone who
sees us at the live shows calls him as
crawdaddy how are you sir I'm fine it
seems to have stuck yes everybody at the
live show used it do we need that mic to
be closer to craw daddy or is it good
always got me he just always leans back
he always leans back because he's got to
keep his pimp hands strong Dave's a
little Stumpy so how's that I'm bringing
it in and uh actually he has been at the
the shows quite a bit so uh Dave and I
of course it's the rebels with a cause
tour we will be in Nashville November
12th and then Baltimore December 3rd uh
we added a second show I should say to
nashville.com it's a 9 30 show I know
many of you conservatives have jobs so
that's late
but it wasn't like Phoenix these anyway
I'm very very grateful I'm very grateful
when you see 5 000 people coming out in
Phoenix and Houston and the Ryman is
like 2400 seats and we had to add a
second show thank you very much from the
bottom of my heart I do not take it for
granted and I expect those seats to be
empty after you see the show Gerald a
how are you sir I'm doing well how are
you today good do you sleep no of course
not you had one good night tonight you
don't need to sleep again you didn't
sing yourself a lullaby I didn't sing
myself a lullaby I should have thought
of that let's see there you go see what
I don't have to sing my kids to sleep I
don't sing myself to sleep yes you need
to treat yourself like someone you care
about said Jordan Peterson so
we have a lot to get to today look it's
sad day okay because a teenager was run
over in you know what the left would
consider a hate crime I'm using that
term because of the term that they use
uh because this team was run over the
motive was stated by the murderer uh to
be politically based that the the
teenager if I'd say kid kid teenager was
a republican extremist that's why he was
killed of course the media isn't
covering this and of course this is the
rule for political violence it comes
from the left it's not the exception so
I don't want you to look at this as an
isolated incident we have some
statistics to discuss uh regarding that
but then we're gonna have some fun
because military recruitment is is down
and the reason is because of lgbtqai so
that's going to be fun
also excess deaths in Europe not fun no
funny
because of the way they try and report
them yes and because of the funny hats
and we'll be careful uh so uh talk about
that question today before we move on uh
is serving in the military you think it
still Garners the same respect that it
used to
um you can check with anyone in your
room who's watching right now who thinks
so I don't think so okay
so uh name that movie line uh
it's a movie Life first we have to it's
can you get a root beer for anyone who
wants one I don't want one okay I always
get to laugh I don't know that I would
have been able to figure that out I know
I know you know I know but that's true I
know you know yeah and you know that I
know that you know that's right that's
that's okay but I'll let others Charming
oh geez Charmin oh boy here we go he's
been playing Biden way too long
um but but that last line
but I know you know that I know that's
okay it's okay it's okay it's not okay
name that movie line as well and we're
just borders starting off and by the way
here's what I do want you to hit the
like button for
okay
it is
scary I think you know where I'm going
with this where am I going Gerald
it is it is Something's Gonna Be scary
no no no
good catch thanks understood this is
scary please tell me it's scary how good
it is scary how good I don't know
someone in this room oh Casey yes sound
board
I don't know
it's Halloween it's scary a whole lot of
things are scary it is scary how good
Yakuza Casey Yakuza is with the
soundboard when we do run through
there's stuff that will never make air
and can't possibly make air he is a
Stephen Hawking so hit the like button
if you can show that guy some
appreciation I love it
he has our names on the soundboard he
doesn't walk in all right so here's
something else just to sort of clear the
palette uh now that we're six minutes in
uh this lady
everyone say lady repeat after me lady
thinks that nuclear weapons
I could now look I'm Pro us having nukes
okay I'm anti-disarmament
however
uh my reason for supporting the United
States having nuclear weapons is largely
because I don't think that evil
superpowers should be the only ones with
those capabilities right you can argue
you may disagree that's why we have the
discussion this lady thinks the problem
with nukes is that they're too masculine
the language that defense intellectuals
use matters in foreign policy because
they are the individuals that decide
foreign policy so if the language they
use about nuclear weapons is highly
sexualized is highly gendered and is
highly sterilized it humanizes the
realities of both nuclear war but also
War Pizza dehumanize the realities of
foreign policy it becomes a lot easier
to make the decision to drop a nuclear
weapon the world of nuclear weaponry has
been traditionally dominated by men so
men were there to create nuclear weapons
they were there to decide to drop
nuclear weapons and they have a specific
language again this has consequences
yeah men did it's crew Men create a
nukes you know what else I created you
blue-haired pumpkin pie haircutted freak
uh the light bulb
the micro electricity the automobile the
automobile hey let me go one step
further tampons birth control
Refrigeration the miracle of flight but
I'm saying we've created stuff that
doesn't even help us I mean the Tampa I
mean the guy was probably tired of
having to change his carpets but the
point is he did it for you
it's a win-win we always ignore it says
men engendered what who speaks about
nukes in a gendered way I want them if
they do yes please be as masculine as
you can possibly be when having to make
that decision I don't want you going
back and forth on how you feel about it
right I think it's more the shape yeah
she has a problem well of course well it
looks like a penis and so we don't like
penises obviously by the blue hair I
always know that when I see a guy
driving his nuke down the street and I
said I know the guy with a small penis
gotta write it like yeah like bombshell
Betty yeah bombshell Betty with a nuke
strap on so my point is uh it's silly
everything is silly and look this why
are we applying gen there's no point
okay
I mean that's real you don't like nukes
isn't that enough right isn't that
enough start there you have to make it
about penises okay
Duke should be toxically masculine yes
exactly right if ever there was a need
for toxic yes if ever I don't what what
do you want you want a softer nuke yeah
I want the nuke to look like the opening
scene in Terminator 2. I want the
skeleton rattling on the grade school
fence because that's why you have a noob
do you want like a loudspeaker the nuke
falling is gender neutral oh well that's
fine I guess let it happen right you
think the Japanese would be like oh no a
giant penis
Batman and a little boy Chris
oh what were the original names of those
you got it right nailed it okay yeah
Batman and little boys I've been a
little boy falling you know look gay
all right here's another thing speaking
of Pricks Rashida Talib
uh is now trying to force people she
tried to persuade Banks that uh they
need to completely divest and I hate
that such a stupid term from fossil
fuels and uh just uh here you get to
watch her persuasive Powers at work
like to ask all of you and go down the
list because again you all have agreed
to doing this please answer with a
simple yes or no does your bank have a
policy against funding new oil and gas
products Mr Diamond
absolutely not and that would be the
road to hell for America
I love that yeah invest in
investing in fossil fuels and in uh in
helping them transition to clean air
energies strike two and Mr um
we are helping our clients make a
transition and that means we're we're
lending to both oil and gas companies
and to new energy companies and helping
monitor the course towards the standards
you're talking about we're kissing watch
this Mr Sharp
oh that's excuse me uh the same thing as
Mr monan said
here's our password yes I'm not going to
ask you Mr Diamond because you obviously
don't care about Working Class People in
Frontline communities like ours oh is
that so terrorist Dame Edna look let's
just
and I knew it was coming I just
never would watch
Frontline Frontline would you consider
yourself front line does she mean to say
marginalized communities you realize
that oil and natural gas they they
create 11 point something million jobs
like something between 11.1 11.5 million
jobs most of whom by the way aren't
Harvard grads these are Working Class
People this is again the gaslighting
that takes place it is fossil fuels are
disproportionately targeting and harming
lower class communities no they're
providing opportunities yes absolutely
and by the way I guess if it's the front
line maybe she's saying that climate
change is racist and affects black
people or that is what they say minority
communities no that is what they say I
know that's what I'm saying I know
saying that it's silly yes yes in so
many words it's pretty stupid the
correct word is [ __ ] I love Jamie he
goes uh no he wasn't happy with no he
was no and that would be the road to
hell for America hell you stupid [ __ ]
Jane you ignorant [ __ ] yes
you're not going to understand this
answer
like the banks to senegree as corrupt as
they are I kind of understand how our
economy works over 77 percent of our
energy here in the states uh come from
fossil fuel 9.6 is nuclear which of
course uh the green heads have a problem
with even though there are zero carbon
emissions and it has the lowest amount
of death or one of the lowest amounts uh
lowest death rates per kilowatt hour
this is just an okay let's just take
this at face value the green New Deal
would that would that help or harm
front-line communities and I guess
Frontline usually means it's
interchangeable with true heroes meaning
nurses and public school teachers right
including the ones who are pedophiles
but with a very small percentage uh
you're the front so now Frontline means
you Rashida clay but representative from
Dearborn who's demanding that Banks stop
providing jobs and stop investing in the
only resource that could possibly power
our economy right now for proof see
California internationally see Germany
you want to take the food out of the
mouths
of African Americans of Latino Americans
it's not even close I think she'd prefer
gas to be at twenty dollars a gallon for
constituents so that they would have to
pay that well it's going to be an
uncomfortable transition but it's going
to be a righteous transition well most
of her constituents came over from
countries that are all about fossil
fuels right that's how they got to
America that's fair it's the only reason
they got to America so and that's the
only reason we do trade with these and
by the way hey I would love to not have
to do any kind of trade yeah with these
countries we don't need any oil from any
of these countries in the middle none
whatsoever
all right by the way it's a live show
Monday through Thursday Dave's going to
be back in uh of course on Monday 10 a.m
Eastern Monday through Thursday you can
watch it on Rumble if you're watching on
YouTube right now or there's a podcast
there's mug club we do chat Thursday
today for another hour nothing would
make me more happy than for all of you
on YouTube right now to go over to
rumble I hear you guys complain and say
why are you on YouTube well why are most
of you watching on YouTube how do you
know we are it's free on Rumble okay you
can go if you don't want to pay for the
extra money please please I I want I
want you to go to rumble I want you to
go to rumble then we've made it
available for you okay uh I guess oh
sorry I'm just kidding uh some breaking
news
[Music]
uh breaking Brian stelter finds himself
in good company with his fellows at the
Harvard Kennedy School
[Music]
to be clear that is a real person that
is a real person at the Harvard Kennedy
School and not a cartoon of a fat person
from Wally
did she eat Brian stelter
I don't know which one is that a she or
a fellow oh gosh I don't know that's
true I may have just misgendered it's
like an Unholy gelatinous Russian
nesting doll it's great because fellow
covers it all yes
hey there my good fellow yeah all right
okay so uh I had to have a little bit of
levity here because this is a a heavy
subject and I think it's an important
subject we have to cover this when it
happens and I think it's important to
remind you of the reality that you are
living unfortunately in this country and
look it's not lost on me that you'll say
well this is being political I'm not
politicizing something when the motive
of the murderer was inherently political
and especially when right now on scene
we've been watching CNN for a while they
have not talked about this you're not
seeing this certainly front line and
Center as you are every time there's
some white shooter who doesn't even have
a motive but they want to say we have a
problem with mass murdering white
Shooters in this case we have a North
Dakota man that's just happened uh he
was arrested for running over a teen and
the reason why he ran over this team
according to him
was that the team was a republican
extremist well I don't understand the
differences 41 year old Shannon Brandt
had a tough time understanding the
charges against him vehicular homicide
and leaving the scene of a deadly
accident he's actually the one that
called 9-1-1 to report the crash police
say it happened in this alley around 2
30 Sunday morning after the street dance
Court paper showed Brent told the 9-1-1
dispatcher that he just hit Kaylor
Ellingson because the teen was part of a
republican extremist group and was
calling people to come get bran after a
political argument
okay so we have a motive stated we have
a reason for the altercation which was a
political argument Joe Lewis hey back to
place
he doesn't want to be here for this yeah
Joe Lewis is uh well he doesn't want to
be here because he just saw that uh the
Kennedy School Harvard Kennedy
um
couple of things uh
I have several problems with this all
right he was charged with vehicular
homicide fling the scene good
first problem released on fifty thousand
dollars bail
that shouldn't happen
okay yeah ran somebody down by the way
this guy's this guy called his mom just
before being killed in the accident
trying to figure out like do you know
this guy that I'm being chased by right
can you believe that can you imagine
getting that phone call as a parent
right scared out of your mind running
from somebody yep
remember how I've talked about this for
a long time hey when you dehumanize your
political opposition when you other them
let's say people who don't wear masks
let's say people who maybe don't get
vaccinated let's say people who maybe
have questions about any at some point
hypothetical election right when you
dehumanize them when you say we need to
fight back against these extremists in
this country and you're talking about 50
of the country when you compare them to
Nazis repeatedly guess what it makes it
okay to treat them inhumanely and here's
something else this is a combination of
not only do we have bail that is way too
low at fifty thousand my I you know I
think the bail should be no bail yeah I
think he kills I think it should be none
right now
um certainly not that quickly but this
is also combined with the entitlement
minus mindset which shouldn't be
surprising considering the murderer was
a liberal uh he wasn't even he wasn't
even able to understand why he would
have to post that kind of bail here's a
quote from Brent I have a job a life and
a house and things that I don't exactly
want to see go by the wayside family
that are very important to me guess what
that kid was family that was important
to someone else you entitled little
prick yeah bring that quote back up for
me for just a second second thing right
there a life he doesn't have it anymore
right the thing that you say that you
have your job your life just stop stop
right there at the second point he
doesn't have it anymore so you don't get
to have you know maybe some freedom for
a little while until we sort this out
right and you know he's saying this is
justification and again this is a
problem of we have a problem with bail
we have a problem with Catch and Release
with with prisoners with violent
hardened criminal the goal of the left
is to turn these criminals into voters
and to turn you into a criminal for
example if maybe you happen to have a
gun that has too many rounds in the
magazine right they want you to be a
criminal
and people like this get released I have
a job I have a life and a house it's the
entitlement mindset that is tied up in
this I want him uh jobless penniless
homeless
lifeless and Bayless you know what we'll
give them a home it's it's got bars
they've got all kinds of people in there
they tend to yell a lot of motion stuff
like that goes to maybe you know angry
raging erections fresh fish home is what
you make it
no he's uh he admitted to enough that
bail shouldn't be shouldn't be on the
table it's like oh okay yeah so you feel
bad about chasing this kid down and
running him over I don't know if the kid
was in the car if the kid was on foot I
don't know the story there but uh you
basically just admitted that you did it
right of course you did that's a
definitely case hey where are they
they're in the Northwest can I ask you
for a small favor I know it's okay
people know that we're doing a live show
let's move the mic a little closer to uh
to Pops Crowder to crawdaddy that way
will you get me well no it's just that
the gain is so people can hear you you
know breathing like a fat guy even
though you're not
um
yeah and that way you can turn it down a
little bit so we're not gonna I have a
CPAP will that help do you do you
actually have a CPAP no of course okay
good
I don't know I hear about that age oh so
um political violence is also we need to
discuss right the leftist wanted you to
believe that political violence is being
perpetrated by the right that's why and
we'll get to uh is it uh I don't know
whichever FBI director I don't know
we'll talk about later
um is it or is it Millie General Millie
um
where they want to use words like
destroy the capital assault the capital
when you're really talking about uh you
know a few dozen let's say a couple
hundred people most of whom were invited
in and only person who was shot was
someone who was entering the capital by
the police they want you to see that as
emblematic of political violence in this
country and here's the thing the
question like I said yesterday is and I
want you to ask yourself this question
and I would love it if you could comment
below this is why we provide all the
references at Lotto with credit.com is
if you ask yourself the question and I
would like to see you in real time ask
the question as you watch the show what
is the strongest argument that my
political opposition will present and
how do you cut it off in the past the
strongest argument that your political
opposition presents is January 6th they
say political violence is coming from
the right really what January 6th
do you have anything stronger they don't
they don't they'll give you a list of a
few white Shooters of course but there
are far more mass shooters by the
definition until they changed it who are
African-American because it's mostly
intergang related in urban areas the
argument that they present is January
6th if there's a stronger one I'd love
to hear it well here's the truth the
2020 riots they were the most
destructive ever in this country okay
the peaceful rights you had 25 people
who were dead in more than 60 000
officers who were injured he had one to
two yeah at least two billion dollars in
Damages these were the clan and these
were only the claims that were made a
few months after we can't find the
updated claims these are just I believe
insurance claims if not mistaken you can
go and find this at axios I don't even
necessarily know that that counts the
government spending that they had to uh
put into repairing infrastructure so I'm
willing to bet the estimate is
significantly higher yeah just sort of
like the doj since they stopped
reporting interrelated interracial
related crime statistics Beyond a
certain year
they just stopped reporting the claims
so you're talking about dozens dead
thousands tens of thousands of officers
injured you're talking about billions of
dollars in Damages and they were
encouraged by this Administration and
the counter argument that the left
points is January 6th this what you are
seeing right now is an extent this is 26
dead if you were just to take the riot
numbers yeah and we're not going to
focus on that at all but we're focusing
on the the billions of dollars in
Damages the media is not going to cover
that when they talk about January 6 and
the damages for that right they're not
gonna they're not going to juxtapose
those two things they're just saying
this is the worst attack in history on
Democracy except for the several other
times in history that there's been
attacks on that building that were far
worse by the way if you've done your
history we talked about it on the show
but go beyond that the communities are
still destroyed not everybody has
insurance right not everybody has the
ability to rebuild not everybody then
had a job to go to the next day after
their job was burned to the ground
largely black communities largely black
communities that have still never
recovered the lingering effect on those
communities is crazy and by the way what
do you think happens when you burn a
City down and you feel like you're
surrounded by people who disagree with
you and you're a conservative you're
like moving somewhere else those places
are still crap holes conservatives got
out yep the only people holding back the
tide were like okay you don't want us as
cops you don't want us as people owning
businesses here sayonor see you later
yeah we're out you know what that
actually brings me to something I want
to mention really quickly
because everyone knows look we talked
about the Derek shopping trial and
obviously and uh um with uh Floyd
um
I don't think that he killed him we've
talked about that with George I don't
think that he did I think it was the
speed ball that being said we talked
about how shopping probably looking at
his history ah sketchy at best I don't
think he was wrong that day if you look
at the full footage okay but let's
assume that you don't like him all right
I'd like to bring something up that a
lot of people haven't discussed because
you've moved remember Mike Brown
remember hands up don't shoot right
remember that [ __ ] part of my language
but I mean that [ __ ] that crock of
steaming corn infested horse [ __ ]
because his hands weren't up
it wasn't a hands up don't shoot his
hands were on a cop's gun and he was
repeatedly assaulting a police officer
that officer going by wrote I think his
name was Darren Wilson a lot of people
don't know this about Darren Wilson he
had been on the force for a while he
could have picked his spot he could have
picked a cushy job he picked working in
Ferguson in a very bad area
because he said you know what these
people meaning these people in these
crime-ridden areas and largely
African-American they need to we need to
build trust with this community and I
think I could be doing more good if I go
in as a white officer and and people in
that Community what they don't what what
this media never told you is he was
actually one of the few cops who was
loved and was trusted he could have
picked a cushy job or he was given out
speeding citations and instead he chose
to serve in a war zone and he was loved
for it and there's a reason you haven't
heard from him since he's had to go away
because of a lie that traveled across
the world hands up don't shoot everyone
acknowledges now that that wasn't true
at all
including the courts it's a matter of
legal record
hands weren't up and it wasn't a random
shot it was self-defense
but that lie traveled across the world
and by the way also spurred on riots and
violence
so there needs to be some kind of
accountability for the actual and I
don't mean figurative I mean active
calls to violence rhetoric that actively
calls Divine it is kind of ironic isn't
it when the left when they talk about
Free Speech they say well well what do
you think I'm going to say what's the
most tired argument when they say well
free speech is an absolute what do these
people say well crowded theater crowded
theater thank you crowd it is you can't
y'all firing a credit Peter actually you
can if there's a fire dumbass you can't
lie and call people to an action to
cause a stampede that could actually
cause physical harm for the same reason
that you can say oh I hate that person
boy I'd really love to kill them you can
say that if you're just speaking
figuratively what you can't say is I
will pay you fifty thousand dollars to
kill this person it's the action taking
place it's the call to a violent action
and isn't it ironic that these people
who said well Free Speech isn't absolute
because you can't yell fire in a crowded
theater missing the fact that it's a
call to a violent action are
consistently calling people to Violent
actions and we shouldn't be surprised
statistically it's true the violence
comes from the left references available
at earthquake.com and just when you're
talking about the logic test
you have heard them call for me saying
okay they rated the uh they wrote it
right in Mar-A-Lago This Is War coming
on air saying I'm not talking about a a
physical War I'm not talking about a
call to arms or call to violence and
they run it on CNN on a loop like a
morphine drip people saying it's time to
Riot in the streets
not a peep there's a difference
between rhetoric and calling people to
violence and the same people who say
well free speech is an absolute because
you can't call people to violence
consistently call people to violence and
that's what you're experiencing this
morning remember that the next time you
have that pit in your stomach reference
the sources that we have available for
you because it's not ill-founded it's
not ill-founded
it's uh
oh boy that bit landed worse than cardi
B on a Pummel horse I know that's why
I'm having a call Button installed here
oh so you can get more drinks no so you
can get food service no so I can get
John Wilkes Booth all right that's
enough I don't know why we have that
balcony installed there I'm sorry that
was me okay did you have anything that
you wanted to add there sorry I know I
kind of no you nailed it fired up today
yeah you absolutely nailed it it's wrong
cardi b and a pommel horse he did okay
that man
good imagery good visual it is I do
appreciate that but I still don't like
them
Joe Lewis doesn't like him either see
look he's unhappy about it oh he doesn't
look unhappy he just looks tired he
doesn't look tired he looks like he
always does oh that's always what he
does that's why it's so scary when he
when he pumps the gas yeah and he like
hits the gas you're like oh my God he
just leaps in the air like a gazelle he
cleared an eight-foot fence once what
like it was nothing you serious like it
was absolutely nothing and there wasn't
even anything on the other side of that
fence he was bored I feel like it's just
a matter of time until they rule us
hemar ran up the side of it and then
vaulted over well he jumped and then
used his front legs
oh my God
we live by his grace he's thinking of
all the times that I faked him out with
the ball and he's just he could have
just killed me he's holding it in his
memory one night very funny oh God okay
so here's another do we have a a clip
from the news or no on the uh the
military issue if not that's fine
we do yeah okay so let me just set this
up for you um on Tuesday the National
Guard and this is and this is something
that has been a long time coming
but this is a significant shortfall yeah
uh the military in the United States
which is very very different from the
military that probably thank you of
course to All Veterans and people who
have served I want you to understand
that this is not at all to shortchange
your contributions but I think we can
all acknowledge that the military right
now is not what the military used to be
and this is the reason that there is a
shortfall uh as far as the recruiting
goals and the story here is not that
there's a shortfall it's that the
military can't possibly understand why
but I have a hunch but don't take my
word for it other people have recognize
this the state-by-state fight over
abortion rights could also become a
factor military personnel station that's
not the right clip okay so we'll bring
that up later uh nine thousand let me
bring it up at CBS News I think from CBS
News 9 000 is a military shortfall for
recruit recruiting they only hit 52 of
their goal ah just over half yeah
[Laughter]
getting great and Junior High majority
what do you give that that's way below F
there's got to be another one is it I
mean it is
at least have an e in Canada you guys
Canadians out there do you remember did
you guys have an e we had e we had ABCD
just had a percentage score though we
had a percentage score but we had an e
we also had a scoring for effort
ah I scored very low on both
participation trophies in class no I was
the only one they didn't give a
participation trophy really yeah that's
mean it was more of a shame thing then
we had a conduct Mark yes yeah yeah okay
hold on before I move on this this is a
true story with pop scrotter what was it
that your report card said that you were
mocked for forever
loud and abusive and or becomes
defensive when criticized
foreign
I don't know where I get it okay so only
hitting 52 of their goal that's pretty
bad yeah uh here's a question for you
and I think we should all ask right what
is causing this shortfall do you have
that's nice
what's causing the shortfall now I want
to get to again what's the strongest
argument that the left is going to
present we're going to do the same thing
with the excess European deaths yeah
hint the easiest argument is covered
related okay so hint here what's causing
the shortfall well okay couple of things
let me first give you some facts only 23
of 17 to 24 year olds in America are
even fit to serve uh that's due to
criminal records uh health problems
sorry I mean being large and beautiful
don't fat shame yeah exactly don't fat
Shane let's and that's going to be next
by the way lizzo's signing up yeah lizzo
in fatigues
no she's just fatigued
she's listless so uh 23 not fit to serve
and uh only nine percent of them even
had any proclivity desire to do so oh
wow
so the next question is why aren't
eligible Americans joining the military
you know people who aren't crazy or
obese well okay here are some of the
experts uh making their claims this is
what they will claim and when I say
experts I mean experts by their
definition no not by mine I say uh
ignorant
so uh here's their first claim that they
will try and present to you and that'll
tell you why it's wrong uh Luke Coffey
veteran senior fellow at the Hudson
Institute right he's trying to cut you
off the pass and say well by the way I
know what you're thinking and it's the
wokeness stuff all the you know the
three mommies commercials
um is it that's the wokeness has nothing
to do with why we have a shortfall in
the military here he is no there's this
perception about the military is going
woke and there are all these cultural
Wars inside the inside the military but
to be honest with you I'm not sure how
much of that actually trickles down to
that young 18 year old recruit from
Middle America who's trying to decide
what he or she wants to do uh to to
improve themselves in their future some
times you get the face you deserve right
well you said it with a smile so it has
to be you know is that the term we're
going with yeah we'll
trickle down or between 18 year old poor
choice of words freaky batboy man
that's ad hominem yep
yep so that's the first well I don't
think the wokeness has anything to do
with it okay here's another claim that
they're going to make
which should just show you again these
are the claims they are making they're
presenting these arguments that's why I
make the references publicly available
uh Army uh correspondent uh date
foreign
the guy's an ass and his name is David
winky okay
the disdain pretty much takes care of
itself now he is reporting and this has
been going out in multiple press
releases and of course the media picks
it up uh they've been reporting that
some of the shortfall
could be due to limited abortion access
the state-by-state fight over abortion
rights could also become a factor
military personnel station in one state
could have access to abortion rights
While others may not there's a potential
that you'll have some folks who are
hesitant to join because they don't know
if they're going to get sent somewhere
where they don't have access to health
care that they believe is a human right
right yeah now see this is also where I
would argue that we've gotten so far off
the beam
um it's not so much that abortion
shouldn't be
um a pivotal issue when thinking about
joining the military uh I don't think
that people out in the battlefield
should be getting pregnant
so that's fair yeah it shouldn't be it's
not really right it shouldn't be the
equivalent to Tinder
think about what we're now talking about
like maternity suits if maybe you guys
can bring that up there from the
controller remember when Joe Biden was
saying we're going to invest however
many it could be Millions it could be
billions into stretchy flight suits for
pregnant Pilots anyone out there
comment below you ever had a pregnant
wife or have you been a woman who's been
pregnant you know you're not allowed to
fly past a certain point right
but you want to have a female goose with
a baby bump at eight months yeah what
are the g-force is going to do to the
child inside come on wouldn't the G suit
starve it of of much needed blood
probably so scrambled eggs by the way I
don't know how many oh geez
I was trying to move on and you just
won't let me I don't know how many women
are thinking like oh well gosh if they
send me to this state I just I won't be
able to have an abortion are you
thinking that far in advance you're like
I'm gonna [ __ ] myself out to as many
people as possible and if I get pregnant
I want the right to kill this child
because I don't want to have any
responsibility don't bring to me the
rape and incest argument we know how
much of a low percentage that is in a
lot of these states do have exceptions
for that so understand that but really
is that the thinking that he's saying
well women they're just probably
thinking they don't want to join because
they could be sent to like I don't know
Texas yeah yeah what do they think
they're going to be sent to boot camp
it's going to be Liam like now walk up
to my head and abort yourself right now
were you about to call me a
gender-neutral [ __ ]
this guy actually say that the 18 year
old demographic was not the woke one
that it wouldn't trickle down to them I
don't think it's gonna how is it down to
this eight what was the money token now
and spent on them 540 000 spent on 2000
one piece maternity flight suits and I
guess two-piece flight suits and wrap
dresses are on the way whatever 540
000 divided by
2000 it's too much
it's too much good Lord but if you're
gonna go with them if you're gonna go
one piece or two piece I prefer two
piece how about you piece man that's me
Mr old-fashioned shoes don't mess with
me I'll also permit tassels no so
they're saying it's not because of the
woke thing and they're saying it could
be because of the lack of abortion
here's the truth okay to their claims uh
uh look most of the recruits at least
for the in the recruits that you want in
the recruits historically
don't come from the demographics that
would complain about not being able to
get abortions by the way they also would
uh when we're talking about the
demographics they would want sex change
operations and they would want the
abortions to be funded by the taxpayer
because they're in the military most of
these people are not the people who you
are actively seeking to recruit not just
because many of them are gross but women
are physically weaker so now we have the
example of I'm not saying that women
can't be working comms or women can't be
Pilots provided they're not knocked up
I'm not saying that women can't be
supportive of the military hey you know
what before I go on with this can you
can you feminists and liberals can you
also just take a moment to accept how
shittily you are treating the legacy of
women in the middle you know we had a
war effort in this country in World War
II right yeah you're a bombshell Betty
comes from do you mean it do you mean to
say that their role wasn't as important
as the men because I would never say
that I don't think that only grunts are
the real soldiers and only grunts are
the one protecting this country there
were women supporting their men abroad
not making a dime
whether it's stitching whether it was
making parachutes whether it was putting
rations together they were doing it with
the military and they were doing it in
their communities what happened to it it
takes a village we now want to act as oh
well because women have been
discriminate hey I don't think they've
been discriminated they've been
discriminated against in some capacities
but I don't think that they haven't been
allowed to serve in the military I think
there are complementary roles and I
think that their role was really
important dare I say if not for
wonderful broads we would have never
would have won World War II okay the
fair point broads I like them the Uso
yes you know we're talking about real
lemon or Bob Hope dressing up like a
woman well before that was fashionable
yeah
it's a morale so the truth is let's look
at the actual demographics okay uh let's
take a look at first like rural versus
major cities okay 2005 a pentagon report
on recruiting data uh 44 of recruits
came from rural America with only 14
coming from major cities uh that they
say major cities because they can't
write um cesspools where dreams go today
Democrat hell holes yes
holes of [ __ ] I would never say that
that's what they say oh they tell me
what a hole of [ __ ] so
rural youth voters by the way even
keep my rule voters period it's even
more more Stark than this but rural
youth voters still are overwhelmingly
overwhelmingly Republican yeah 60 in the
last election 2020. 60 percent
of white rural voters in 2020 Donald
Trump Biden 37 now we'll do the the
breakdown here as far as when it comes
to sex and I say sex because you want to
say gender I don't uh the makeup of the
military 82 percent man 82.5 percent men
and about 70 percent of those men have
active duty males anyways are white hmm
okay female 17.6 so we have 82.4 and
17.6 can you do the math what does that
add up to I I think a hundred that adds
up to 100 on the nose where are the
other genders how dare you and where
will they get their abortions what about
the plus I've heard so much about this
Plus at the end yes
it's the LGBT like subscription service
that you have to buy that's right get
more of it that's another level yes
that's the slogan is more accurate now
Army of one because you can copulate
with yourself
so
100 and then by the way 6.1 percent
identifies LGBT so if this seems
confusing to you that means that the 6.1
percent is rolled into the 100 of male
and female so you are either male or
female and you may be LGBT the point is
if it's confusing and you can't keep
track of it that's by Design
now speaking of gender this is changing
a new study has found that transgender
people are twice as likely to serve
so that may be the reason for the
catering that they're doing now they
genuinely think well we need to fix the
abortion thing or we won't have enough
recruits well we need to start running
ads with two or three mummies but let me
give you some numbers here even if 100
of all transgender people join the
military assuming the numbers and the
percentage of population which is vastly
overestimated pure research says it's
five percent
I guarantee you it's not that high no
um if 100 of trans people ages 8 to 29
were to enlist minus the 42 who attempt
suicide that would leave somewhere
around a million that's a significant
number but that's assuming that all of
them join up also this is important
you cannot join them when you watch the
same video we have the references
available you can't join the military
they're saying in some cases if you have
ADHD as an adult yeah if you were to
have attempted suicide or if you were in
a demographic that has a 41 to 43
attempted suicide rate
in any other community any other
demographic not called trans you would
be turned away
they're making an exception because
they're not allowed to not if you were
to say yeah by the way I'm not saying
they're all transparent I'm not I'm just
drawing I'm making an analogy I'm a
paranoid schizophrenic and we're the
only other demographic that exists or
has existed throughout the history of
mankind who has a suicide right even
close to those of transgenders that is
true that includes American slaves that
includes Jews and Auschwitz no one
nowhere else nowhere else not not gays
not American slaves no one has a 40 plus
attempted suicide rate if you were part
of that demographic and you walked into
a recruitment office they would say oh
wait hold on a second everything looks
uh good here wait a second you're not a
part of that community that has an over
40 attempted suicide rate are you
no good enough for me chick with dick
that's one of the questions that I would
have are they are they already
transitioned by the time that they get
there or are they basically just doing
it a name and want to get because the
benefits are there
to get the surgery in some instances yes
yeah but we've seen that right with uh
What uh Manning I think I don't know
what the that's because we spare no
expense in creating the finest fighting
force the world has ever seen or so I
mean I thought the bionic human thing
was going to be like ah these are super
soldiers so now we're just like ah we're
lopping stuff off I'm like well this is
out female to male trans what standards
would they have to adhere to in the
military that's another thing which I
just go in and say I'm a woman and only
have to do 10 push-ups in a minute right
but going the other way now it hurts
them it's always a help coming back to
the that's true yeah and notice you
don't have any female to males
dominating men's sports
hmm yeah you can't do one pull-up sir
I'm trans oh we apologize then we'll do
we'll do a 10 second hanging you just
hang there for 10 seconds you know what
better not around sugar britches run
around better yet just go sit in this
recliner and uh sign this NDA yep there
we go we're sorry we apologize please do
whatever you like please don't don't
call Brian stelter
I mean really we're at this it could it
shouldn't be relevant the military is
supposed to be a completely apolitical
organization okay by Design you are
supposed to be a faceless nameless
number because you are now a part of a
unit
I shouldn't know
about your fake gash
think about that in any military and and
if you're dying in your bed with your
real dick many days from new
would you trade all the [ __ ] days
just for one day like all right all
right that's enough that's enough
William you did it too quickly we're not
quite over that hump I get the mooning
of the army but when you Moon and I see
the bandage from your fight back
[Laughter]
can't do it it looks like Brian stelter
standing backwards holding an apple
it doesn't exactly do a lot to Boost
Mobile William
so
here's my we have to do that sketch if
that doesn't offend you hit the like
button because it helps with the
algorithm hit like hit share it's the
only thing that keeps us well mug Club
Keeps Us afloat of course but it's what
uh keeps us going here on YouTube I like
the new gavel all right yeah yeah I like
to get one it's a silly gamble so here's
a question that I have for you
considering that this is what they
believe to be pivotal right where
they're talking about abortion okay
um do we think that these woke and
considering who we need to be in the
military
do we think that these woke recruiting
ads where this man who just said the man
with the face he deserves said I don't
really think the wokeness is trickling
down I don't really think that's uh I
don't think that's pivotal okay then why
are your ads
more woke than a buzzfeed boldly clip I
don't even know if that's still a thing
if you guys remember it was fat women
who used to do things BuzzFeed boldly
yes boldly as opposed to BuzzFeed
demurely
are these woke recruiting ads
this is from the military is this
attracting the right kind of soldier
[Music]
thank you
okay let's pause let's pause
you guys notice anything
you guys notice anything there
now again when I say it's vast majority
of the military is male and 70 of those
active duty in the military are white
males
what we're talking about
equal or accurate representation all
right you know what okay it's a trick
it's a trick question sorry like the
Burger King kids club there yeah but
except without the white guy and the
visor and the handheld TV let's keep
playing it
although I had a fairly typical
childhood took ballet
played violin
I also marched for equality
when I was six years old one of my moms
had an accident that left her paralyzed
I'm sorry one of my Mom's doctor said
she might never walk again
but she tapped into my family's plan to
get back on her feet I'm your mom
eventually standing at the altar to
marry my other Mom she'll pass me to
your requirement approach my other mom
who is gross also so much in life a
sorority girl said she'd never scissor
it one of my sorority sisters was
serving abroad in Italy another was
climbing Mount Everest
I needed my own Adventures
my own challenge
and after meeting with an army recruiter
I found it a way to prove my inner
strength and maybe shatter some
stereotypes along the way
[Music]
and I answered
I'm sorry was that a hyphenated last
name I don't know Emma Malone Lord yeah
there was a song written about Riding
With Private Malone maybe that's the
that's not her vision well not as
they've changed it to riding with
Malone's privates it's just just a
severed penis hanging there yeah I'm a
private no it became Sandra Malone
um why does why does any of what just
happened to their matter and then why do
they get to run that ad and then say
well I don't know why people are
complaining that it's wokeness in the
military all because of you because of
you because of that because of the fact
that you had the woman climbing up the
rope and then down they're opening up
they're opening down they're open then
rolling our eyes back in Bliss that's
the problem you know what I want to do I
want to play the opening scene uh from
I'm forgetting the movie name right now
with Tom Hanks storming the beach
Saving Private Ryan I should not forget
that name went away in my head it's just
I want to play that and be like all
right guys everybody sit here and look
at this this is Matt thank you that was
deserved this might be what you have to
do are you willing to do it
[Music]
that's what I want the military ads to
be like this is going to be a tough day
this is not a I get to call them Beach
could I get like the Canadians like Juno
because I'm still sore from my abortion
we'll give you Juno or sword you can
take either one you can kind of walk
ashore I didn't get my two abortion
weeks I mean I just kind of wanted to
fly a drone yeah yeah I like how she's
on one side of the wall on the rope and
then they shoot the reverse on the other
side and it's animation they could have
made her actually climb it in the
animation what's hilarious is that she
jumped down to like a 15-foot wall then
landed like a superhero because that
happened no no they couldn't have made
her climate because here's here's what
you're missing they couldn't have made
her climate in the animation because by
animation you're only limited by your
imagination
so here's the thing can I just say one
thing while we're dealing with the
military you're done you're done people
who try and [ __ ] about accurate and
diverse representation okay that is
completely inaccurate that
representation in the military because I
didn't see a pinch of skull in any cheek
okay that's how you know it's [ __ ]
and we hear Oscar's so white Oscar this
is happening Oscar's so what armies
insert whatever here so what it's the
reason that I wasn't uh invited on the
bill Marshall when I went through the
screen and they wanted me to talk about
Russia I said I don't know the number
one Trend right now is hashtag Oscar so
white and I just saw Mary J Blige fold
into an armoire in slash Queen in 1740
slavery France okay this is wise because
there is no accurate historical
representation and there isn't an
accurate representation of not only what
exists in the military but what you want
in the military let's be honest what you
want in the military is you want some
leather-necked hillbilly who's going to
be out there shooting [ __ ] anyway only a
swapping his hunting rifle with an M16
or M4 and you swap the deer with a
Jihadi that's the person you want not
someone who's shouting their period And
this is another example I just watched
this with my kids for example if you
want to talk about accurate
representation you want to talk about
cultural appropriation this is a new
film with and I should it's an okay film
just to be clear
Sea Beast
see I think it's a Netflix Disney Pixar
I don't know Netflix and see if you
notice an issue here these are pirates
on the high seas see if it can spot what
may not have been all too common
[Music]
thank you
these are pirates
these are pirates after that she was
after that she was raped mercilessly
these are pirates who are oh yo what do
you think they're going to do on the
high seas for two years away from a
single from from a single female only to
find themselves well blessed with an
athletic broad on the ship butthole no
the unspoken truth
[Laughter]
fine did we also find by the way the uh
yeah
so we have the overlay from the queen
and Beauty and the Beast sorry the the
live-action version yeah Audrey McDonald
oh Audra McDonald yeah I'm sorry yeah
yeah here comes a nice armoire yeah I
guarantee you you found that all over
1740s France
#oscar so what can you take your wins
and now you have it with the military
and what they do is they put again you
can either have equal opportunity or you
can try and ensure equal outcome and in
this case not even equal outcome you can
try and ensure predetermined outcomes
based on race based on ethnicity based
on gender I guess because we're not
saying sex based on sexual orientation
if you try and ensure that well guess
what you're just going to end up pruning
the people who are most qualified and
you want fighting to defend your country
it's that simple so here's another
question that I might ask you while
we're talking about this if it's not
about wokeness and that plays no role
well then why do you make it such a big
part
of getting ready for the military when
for example the Navy makes Sailors
Sailors remember them they make Sailors
read critical race Theory books in the
Navy well yeah
that's probably right up their alley
yeah but here's what uh uh Mark milley
right the U.S chairman of the Joint
Chiefs of Staff this is what he had to
say about critical race Theory and
whiteness and notice the military Garb
on the issue of critical race Theory Etc
a lobbyists have to get much smarter on
whatever the theory is
um
but I do think it's important or on
anything what uh for those of us in
uniform to be open-minded and be widely
read and the United States Military
Academy is a university and it is
important that we train and we
understand uh and I I want to understand
white rage and I'm white and I want to
understand it so what is it that cause
thousands of people to assault this
building and try to overturn the
Constitution of the United States
capital what caused that I want to find
that out I want to maintain an open mind
here and I do want to analyze it it's
important that we understand that
because our soul to Sailors Airmen
Marines and Guardians they come from the
American people so it is important that
the leaders now end in the future do
understand it
okay
so much wrong there
um
again they can't turn around and say oh
Wellness has anything to do with it the
only reason is it does have anything to
do with is because you push it
incessantly and by the way in saying hey
they have uh trans people are two times
as likely right twenty percent of trans
people are likely have served in the
military in trying to push a woke
narrative and by the way in bashing
America this is kind of an irony that
the United States military the
industrial complex now is kind of
playing in the part and parcel of
bashing the United States of America the
people who typically went into the
military were the people who were
patriotic the people who wanted to serve
their country and then they were spit on
the filthy hippies when they came home
now those filthy hippies uh reside in
the offices of the military and so now
they actually feel guilt and they have
to make up for that guilt one in the
military but trying to change
demographics by trying to change the
goals of the military by trying to make
sure that the military isn't actually
instilling some sense of national pride
but gender identity pride and this is
something that was interesting to me and
I think Kevin Elaine brought this up
um
patriotism in America uh has declined
right ever since 2001 Gallup started
measuring it okay now this is important
because the percentage of Democrats
since 2001 who have responded that they
are extremely proud to be American it's
Fallen by 40 contrast that with
Republicans at nine percent so we know
that typically speaking right we would
imagine that rural Republicans the
people who made up the military were
more patriotic so the fact that they are
less patriotic by a smaller degree isn't
a surprise but think about that that's
during eight years of Obama which by the
way was when we saw the most radical the
most fundamental changes to our economy
and the fabric of our country uh during
those eight eight years and then of
course almost two years of Biden
what does that tell you
that tells you that Republicans that
conservatives are still largely proud of
their country regardless of who is in
office in other words they can say I
don't like this Administration I don't
like the way the government is going I
don't like that direction but I still
think this country as it's meant to be
is the greatest country in the face of
the Earth that's the country those
people have wanted to fight for and
instead you're discarding them and
saying no no we want the Democrats who
by the way 40 it's Fallen by 40 percent
the people who even when they've had
every single branch of government for
years and they've had radically changing
policies implemented in this country and
they still hate their country we want
those people on the front lines fighting
for our country do you see see how
perverse that is and you know why do you
know why their patriotism has fallen
there is for the same reason the
patriotism from conservatives has fallen
significantly less why because they love
what this country is meant to be they
don't like the way what they view as the
elites they don't like the direction
they're pulling it Democrats are not pop
and I mean liberals left us they are
losing their patriotism because they
don't think that we've eroded our
country enough they don't like this
country they don't like the Constitution
they've told you that they've told you
that when they decided that it was
racist and that these the Constitution
is out of date they told you that when
not just when they decided to take down
statues of Confederates statues of
Abraham Lincoln statues of George
Washington Democrats lose their
patriotism even when they have full
control because it's not enough of a
change they want us to become socialist
[ __ ] Europe South take your pick
whatever country it is it in the United
States and Republicans conservatives
lose their patriotism when they feel
like we are getting away
from being the ogs so for two very
different reasons if you see patriotism
falling declining the motive matters ask
the why well and it's not surprising
when you see our senior military leaders
like we just saw with Millie saying
thousands of people attacked this
building right so we're still pushing
the January 6th narrative it wasn't
thousands of people by the way it wasn't
just white people because then you talk
about white rage right as well linking
those two things together no no people
weren't just mad it wasn't a race issue
there wasn't anything going on by the
way Donald Trump was incredibly popular
in the Hispanic and black communities so
don't act like he was the racist in
Chief in office like everybody's been
saying and you're trying to tie these
things together as though you don't know
what critical race theory is you're the
do you think you went into that meeting
do you think he sat down at that table
to answer questions without knowing what
the questions were going to be that's
not how those committees typically work
here are the topics we're going to talk
about they tend to brief you on those
things so that you can have the
information you need do you think he
didn't know that or was he just playing
into the CRT doesn't exist we didn't
even know what that is and then he goes
into some of the components in CRT yeah
and says that well I want to understand
that I should probably be more educated
do you think you're the guy in charge
it's like crg doesn't exist uh I have a
400 handbooks that you handed out well
your guess is as good as mine well they
say uh CRT by uh Yours Truly uh General
Miley you like how this graph that we
build up from Gallup that clearly shows
Democrats you know trending downward the
title of the graph is Republicans Pratt
and being American drops
goodness yeah it drops slightly less
yeah well he said he didn't uh he needed
to read up more on educate himself and
then he had an opinion on it right and
then you've got a military General whose
assessment of an assault was so grossly
inaccurate right he's just disqualified
himself he has shown himself to be
completely disqualified are you sure
about that 2 000. imagine two thousand
imagine if that man has to give an
account from the battlefield yeah and
that's how accurate he is with his
assessment right it's like wait a second
you're saying that we need to drop the
Moab how how many do the insurgents kill
uh uh I don't care that uh zero none but
I think this is the most prudent course
of action because I'm a prick drop it
twice yeah there's no wokeness but his
assessment was based on it yes right and
but we're gonna have to we're gonna have
to hit the uh UK deaths uh we'll hit it
next week by the way just a secret hint
uh these aren't covered related when you
look at the demographics and people are
the left is trying to say that it's code
related ah the left is trying to say
that's Heatwave uh Heat Wave related ah
we'll get to that next week and sink our
teeth in but let me recap this segment
here and again if you share the show
like it whatever you can do is is
helpful because it helps the demographic
we're going to mug Club taking your
chats
um the recap what do we know okay
the military can't recruit they're not
hitting their numbers they're missing
their numbers by about half I'm rounding
upward
give her minus two percent
uh it comes right on the heels of them
pushing incessantly awoke narrative that
we have seen culturally and we have seen
through data points people are rejecting
and certainly the people who you most
likely want to join the military so
they're in doing this they can't recruit
they're pushing a woke narrative and it
is actively alienating their largest
demographic name me namely sorry uh
white males namely males namely let's
just say people from rural areas so even
if they're women they're largely coming
from rural areas they're more likely to
be conservative they're most likely to
be men overall and if they're men
they're more likely to be these are the
people who Once Upon a Time joined the
military and why for the same reasons
that we see these people often have a
very high level of patriotism so what
happens you can't recruit you can't
recruit because of you put you push the
vote narrative and abortion would insert
whatever the hell it is here they're not
joining the military because they can't
get sex change operations whatever it is
that you want to say and we've now
alienated the largest demographics who
by the way are in general most capable
uh to be in our front lines what's the
end result what's the end result
the same end result as when you try to
ensure
A diversity of representation in the
police force and you just watch that
female cop get her ass kicked by an old
man
the citizens are less safe
Americans are less safe and here's the
thing
when I say Americans are less safe I'm
just looking at the demographics of
people make up the military yep majority
men yep majority white yep majority rule
voters yep majority Trump voter okay
that's just the makeup of the military
they protect
all demographics
so in trying to ensure equal outcomes in
the military as some kind of a social
experiment you have now caused actual
physical
damage and certainly compromise the
security
of everyone straight okay trans white
black latino you know what even the
illegal immigrants who've come here
seeking a better life in trying to
socially engineer the military it's not
that they're when people translate oh
these culture wars what it doesn't exist
in a vacuum we're less safe because of
what you've done with the police force
we're less safe with what you've done to
the FBI we're less safe with what you've
done to the FDA and we are certainly
less safe because of what you and when I
say you why am I making a generalization
because it's true we're less safe
because of what you the left the
anti-American bordering on communist
left has done with the military I hope
the Lost lives of all demographics are
worth it you can go through so you can
go screw yourself with a wire brush
we're going to see you Monday Dave's
going to be back in that chair what do
we have something what we've got the the
we want to make sure we tell people
where to go oh I know what was this
it's delicious that's what it is Patriot
Supply by the way these are actual
Patriots uh there are food shortages
that are coming up you don't need to
wait to prepare for emergencies God
knowing what we see with our military
right now who knows
it could just be a flood yeah difficult
you know if you decide to rebuild with a
city that's still below sea level what
could possibly go wrong there uh if
you're in an area that's really cold
where things freeze like the ice storm
that we live through it's always just a
good idea to have three months three
months supply of food if you can
per person so go to prep with
crowder.com you'll save 250 on a
three-month emergency food supply prep
with crowder.com and I will tell you
this they've actually their oatmeal is
better than but you probably shouldn't
just like go into your stash like I do
with the oatmeal and pudding it's not
for it's meant to be used in an
emergency yeah I know I know not going
to be there when you but it's delicious
prep with credit.com everyone else go
screw yourselves we're gonna go to chat
Thursday we'll see you Monday back with
Dave
foreign
[Music]